laurent chatel chai connaît bien les
virus d'origine animale notamment celui
de la dengue et le zii cas qu'ils
étudient pour mieux les comprendre
selon lui il suffit de regarder la
séquence génétique d'un virus pour voir
qu'il n'a pas été créée par l'homme dans
un laboratoire
et lakovic 19 ne fait pas exception
l'unité fonctionnelle qui nous intéresse
ici c'est ce groupe de gènes qui codent
pour des protéines qui vont former les
nouveaux virus et notamment cette
protéine hla qui s'appelle spike qui est
à la surface du virus c'est elle qui
permet l'entrée du virus dans une
nouvelle cellule
et quand les gens ont commencé à
regarder les premières séquences de ce
virus là il s'est rendu compte que
j'avais une région qui était très très
très intéressante mais qui contenait des
éléments qui était inhabituel pour un
coronavirus y avait des ressemblances
avec certains éléments du vih et tout ça
les gens commençaient à spéculer que
peut-être sort été intégrée par l'eau
alors qu'en fait d'autres séquences
semblables de coronavirus circulait déjà
chez d'autres animaux
je pense que la nature est bien meilleur
que l'homme pour faire des virus
pathogènes l'histoire de l'humanité la
prouver nous on est très bons pour
répondre aux défis mais crée un
pathogène de toutes pièces pour moi
c'est de la science fiction
[Musique]
la théorie selon laquelle la commune 19
étaient fabriqués par des scientifiques
trouve son origine dans ce laboratoire
chinois de one la région où tout a
commencé
le laboratoire est classée niveau p4
avec des mesures de sécurité les plus
exigeantes du monde dans ses
laboratoires
on va garder des souches extrêmement
virulente de virus ou de bactéries y en
a un au canada qui est à winnipeg le
laboratoire chinois possédait-il donc le
virus
il ya peut-être un travail de
surveillance qui a été fait par les
autorités chinoises pour voir les virus
circulant dans la faune avoisinantes et
peut-être qu'ils ce virus-là avait été
identifié après cultiver c'est aussi une
possibilité
alors il y aurait-il pu y avoir une
fuite au laboratoire c'est peu probable
selon le chercheur même moi dans mon
laboratoire
je travaille des vidéos ce qui ne
doivent pas sortir du laboratoire c'est
pour ça qu'on a des règles de
biosécurité dans un laboratoire p4 il
faut quand même savoir que les gens sont
quasiment dans des combinaisons
d'astronautes qui sont six oxygène il ya
des règles très strictes
l'hypothèse de l'origine du virus la
plus probable proviendraient pour
l'instant d'un endroit pas très loin du
laboratoire de buran dans un marché
public
se trouve être le supermarché à des
pauvres
sylvain quessy et professeur en études
vétérinaires dans le cadre de son
travail il a visité plusieurs de ses
marchés publics en asie qu'on appelle
marché humide les gens qui sont en
campagne il ya souvent à pau d'épicerie
ou de supermarchés donc dans ces
endroits là c'est clair que c'est la
seule façon dont les gens peuvent
s'approvisionner les ouates market ou
marché humide font partie de la
tradition alimentaire en asie dans la
majorité de ses marchés on trouve des
fruits des légumes de la viande fraîche
et des fruits de mer
cependant dans certains d'entre eux on y
achète des animaux exotiques comme des
serpents des rats dépend des porcs-épics
ou même des pangolins on les appelle
marché humide parce que comme il n'ya
pas de réfrigération les marchands
arrosent leurs produits d'eau et de
glace pour essayer de les garder au
frais ils sont de véritable nid à virus
avec une promiscuité entre l'humain des
espèces domestiques et des espèces plus
exotiques ou sauvage donc son écologie
absolument idéal pour que des virus
puissent se changer entre des espèces
qui normalement ne devrait pas coexister
ensemble et cette cohabitation
inhabituel favorise la transmission du
virus d'une chauve souris par exemple
vers un port où un pont gaulin dont les
récepteurs ressemblent à ceux de l'homme
depuis la pandémie de covile 19 la
pression internationale pour que la
chine ferme ces marchés est énorme mais
le défi est insurmontable
selon sylvain quessy les autorités
sanitaires
tolèrent ces établissements là parce que
c'est indispensable pour que les gens
aient accès à la nourriture
donc on pourrait même penser à l'est pas
à les fermer
c'est un élément clé de
l'approvisionnement des populations
il faut donc s'attendre à d'autres
pandémies dans le futur ce sera
définitivement paul dernier virus auquel
on va devoir s'habituer
ainsi tant que la communauté
internationale ne se penchera pas sur le
contrôle de ces virus d'origine animale
avant qu'il n'arrive à l'humain la santé
mondiale sera toujours en rattrapage
c'est souvent comme ça ce sont des virus
qui franchissent des barrières des
espaces